réactions tout de suite dénis beaudoin
propriétaire du restaurant auguste à
sherbrooke au président de l'association
des gens d'affaires du centre-ville de
sherbrooke on reçoit également péter
sergakis le président de l'union des
tenanciers de bars du québec
bonsoir à vous deux je vais commencer
avec vous madame beaudoin ce soir parce
que du côté des restaurants ça ira un
peu plus vite réouverture des terrasses
de restaurant le 28 mai retour aussi
prochain des zones oranges et des zones
jaunes
ce qui veut dire que les salles à manger
peuvent rouvrir votre première réaction
à ce qui vient d'être annoncé
bah écoutez je veux peut justement être
rabat joie dans tout ça on est très
heureux de je suis la citoyenne est très
heureuse la restauratrice reste sur sa
faim comme un me manque beaucoup
beaucoup de détails dans ce plan de
déconfinement d'ailleurs il faut quand
même attendre dix jours avant de pouvoir
ouvrir les théâtres et un en zone rouge
parfois ça me prend trente six heures
avant de tomber en zone rouge donc oui
on est content mais on a quand même une
bataille à maintenir au niveau de la
restauration
on aimerait quand même envisager ce qui
va se passer après l'été dans la mesure
où si jamais on ne veut pas je peux
passer à l'acte et on veut pas de
variants on veut pas de zone rouge à
l'automne mais on ne veut plus les
restaurateurs payer les frais de la zone
rouge donc fermé les salles à manger
pour nous c'est plus une obscure donc
peut-être que ça paraît vraiment festif
d'ouvrir une terrasse mais premièrement
via un pourcentage assez élevé de
restaurants qui n'ont pas de terrasse il
ya beaucoup de restaurants qui ont de
très petites terrasses on jongle aussi
avec marc nature donc en plein milieu
d'un bon repas un orage ou et arrive on
vient nous dire que les gens peuvent
rentrer minutes avec un masque à
l'intérieur et repartir
donc il ya beaucoup beaucoup de détails
à digérer mais dès lors qu'on vous dit
28 mai terrasse retour rapide des zones
oranges jaunes zone verte et que les
personnes qui auront eu
doses de vaccins peuvent retirer
totalement une masse quand public fin de
la distanciation sociale est ce que vous
voyez pas là toute une série d'étapes
qui nous ramène à quelque chose
d'anormal
oui bien sûr il ya énormément de positif
là-dedans mais je pense que les
restaurateurs nous sommes brûlé et que
nous ne voulons pas payer les frais de
ce déconfinement là la prochaine fois
donc nous demandons d'ouvrir le discours
de revoir les mesures si jamais une
autre zone rouge
on veut s'asseoir on veut parler nous ne
sommes pas une zone de contamination
peut plus payer pour la commune s'est
terminée dans un peu plus farce
je comprends que vous d'accord vous
accueillez enfin cette réouverture
mais en même temps il ya un goût amer
vous craignez donc vous deviez encore
une fois faire mission devait revenir
hors zone rouge aussi à 24e vague ou si
on les chaps il se passe quelque chose
par exemple qu'une explosion de cas donc
vous travaillez le terrain pour que nous
vous ne soyez plus les peler les
commerces et la partie de l'économie qui
est visé par des fermetures tout à fait
gérald on est à pulnoy comme la
récompense pour donne et on allait voir
on dit aux gens mais vous avez été des
bons-enfants vous remettre vos
restaurants non là il faut resserrer la
vis on vous les enlève on sent plus
comme ça dans toute cette histoire le
dont on travaille quand même eu en amont
on aimerait rencontrer les gens on veut
faire partie de la solution pour le
futur puis tant mieux si on a plus de
kobe donc de s'en débarrasser comme
santa oui mais on veut pas une quatrième
vague avec une fermeture des restaurants
comme ça pour tout le québec
message entendu anik beaudoin merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on va se
tourner tout de suite vers peter
sergakis de l'union des tenanciers dans
votre com / gars qui est la réouverture
des terrasses de bars c'est le 11 juin
votre réaction à ce qui vient d'être
annoncé par le premier ministre le go
les conservons à la bonne direction mais
notre problème ce n'est pas fini encore
parce que on n'est pas d'employer les
médias fait plus alors je voulais
vraiment fédérant les arrête
l'épicier parce que c'est fini depuis le
mois de septembre passé le pessimisme ok
mais l'assurance mars qu'ils prennent et
sosuke pas les a passionnés sur ce match
confirme pas ce que parce que les gens
avaient pas des béni travail et non
c'est cette épopée immédiatement il
c'est l'épopée un média demain on les
applaudit devenu travailler parce qu'ils
vont travailler temps partiel parce
qu'il est sale en asie s'est depuis lors
donc il y restera tard ils étaient ainsi
barrés et ont besoin l'aide financière
additionnelle
parce que ça vaut prendre limitée -
mizani va quand on est on voit des
situations avec kobe tu es sérieux
facile je comprends mais est-ce que
d'abord est-ce que vous accueilli
positivement la réouverture des
terrasses le 11 juin et le retour assez
rapide en 1 orange jaune ils ont
ouvertes également qui vont permettre la
réouverture des débats
oui mais un bon direction parce qu'on
est une date
regardez à 100 pour vous préparer
mais notre problème c'est pas fini
encore nous ont donné beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes d'un futur choc
aux fous comme elle et les siens
viennent à dawn établissements viendrait
pas tout de suite parce que pour tout le
monde y va être vaccinés beaucoup de
monde qui vont avoir peur on n'est pas
au tourisme mondial notre problème c'est
long très pénible c'est pour ça que les
gouvernements fou qui cale pour nous
donner l'ontt et financière parce que
vous compensez travers la majorité
littératie au passeport qui va passer à
travers et vous pensez que cette période
justement de transition entre maintenant
puis un retour à la normale
combien de temps pour vous qu'il faut
continuer ou qu'il faut soutenir les
tenanciers de bars moi je pense que
reina après l'ouverture besoin light
parce que les touristes puis beaucoup de
québécois ou canadien qui vaut pour
dalibard parce que une présentation on
parle toujours des alliés quand même ils
veulent attendre pour voir aussi l'écho
vite ils vont diminuer
donc on a les poches 1% la clé un ter
qui vont tourner sinon est ce que vous
voyez quand même la lumière au bout du
tunnel aujourd'hui je suis le gars qui
ce oui oui bon début on naît courage et
avec ça on va commencer plein défilé
d'ouverture mais on est quand même
inquiet pour le futur parce que les
mains des faits pour la wii est bien ici
c'est là le problème
parfait le message est entendu monsieur
sauve gatiss merci d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir ça me fait plaisir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit